meeting have happened last week the men
in suits on their way to see the Prime
Minister and Chancellor a highly unusual
meeting after a highly turbulent few
days
45 minutes later they were out but no
verdict yet on the Fallout we're going
to be providing the chancellor with an
update of our forecast next Friday and
we'll set up a timetable for our
forecast process next week so it might
be brought forward from the 23rd of
November
thank you and did you find her receptive
to what you were saying did you find
them receptive were they helpful we'll
be putting out a statement later on
today thank you the treasury confirmed
following that meeting that an economic
forecast into the impact of that mini
budget is still seven weeks away senior
conservatives had called for it to be
brought forward in order to urgently
calm the storm in the financial markets
and try to get the new government back
on track before it's too late
with more opinion polls showing huge
leads for the labor party even the foxes
in Downing Street sensed the Jitters in
the air as Tory MPS fear voters will run
a mile but a minister insisted there
will be no u-turns we all want the
forecasts to be as quickly as as they
can but also as a former Finance
director I know that you also want them
to have the right level of detail so
that that's where we are in that process
we had to act fast because if we hadn't
have acted tomorrow the first of October
was when in Energy prices were going to
rise across the whole United Kingdom
damaging businesses and households
anything else have you here at the Hope
Center food bank in Derby users say
their cost of living struggles go far
beyond energy bills
Zoe a mother of seven is worried about
her family's benefits being cut it'll
give me any less than literally I'm
going to be homeless because it's going
to be a choice to feed the kids or pay
the rent so it is going to be the
factors that I'm going to be then in
debt with my landlord because obviously
I'm gonna I gotta feed them then a
warehouse worker who was made redundant
has started using this food bank in just
the last few months the price of just
Essentials is going through the roof if
they've got any more
I don't know what I do I mean
unfortunately some people would have to
revert to just stealing the Basic
Essentials
the government insists their reforms
will grow the economy in the end but for
those facing the most difficult of
winters the promises don't stack up
tomorrow Cohen Sky News Westminster